yeah if we just look over here down in
the valley there is where CERN is and
the SPS Collider provides the initial
protons and from those initial protons
they then lead to the generation of the
neutrinos and those neutrinos then fly
off through the mountain range throw
them out through the mountain range
there and over to another set of
mountains in Italy Gran Sasso Mountains
it's amazing to be here and just you
suddenly realize you can talk about it
all you like in a room and you think my
god that's shooting straight through
that rock there what happens when you
Trina [ __ ] Rock nothing absolutely
nothing that's the beauty of neutrinos
and they only interact through the weak
force the weakest of ivali
of all the forces electromagnetism
strong and the weak and the and and they
just don't even notice the rock at all
it's as if the rock might be a bit of
fog that they're just going through and
of course the the exciting result that
they was a poof was announced a few
months back I think in September of 2011
was that the when they took the timing
of the neutrinos that were created and
detected they're created here just
outside of the CERN and then detected in
the Gran Sasso
laboratories worked out the distance and
they knew the time and they worked out
the speed the the velocity of these
neutrinos were fast in the speed of
light and the time difference was just
60 nanoseconds so they were arriving 60
nanoseconds earlier than light would
arrive quite rightly the
experimentalists have been you know
reanalyzing everything they can because
it's such a radical result if it's true
and they're going through everything and
it looks like they've found a couple of
sources of error that may account for
this difference yes so it's to do with
and actually one of them's to do with
the cabling that takes them from the GPS
system that they're using to their own
to their own optical system it's an
optical cable
and it sounds like it wasn't quite
connected well enough and when they've
tightened up the connection the time
delay that was that they were recording
a 60 nanosecond seems to have gone away
completely I'm not an experimentalist
I'm not one to criticize I'm not going
to criticize them because I've had loads
of occasions when I've got headless
wires and I can't get things to transmit
well I think I think that they they've
done things the right way I think they
will get criticism for this a bit tenth
I mean it's still not proven that this
is going to actually screw up the result
because there's there's two effects that
they've noticed one could actually of
course the neutrinos to go even quicker
whereas you know this one is saying that
actually they might go there's two
effects going on they're competing one
another this isn't the only possible
source of error and they've they have
another that we talked about which I
don't really understand which is also to
do with this timing that's again to do
with the coordination between the the
GPS system that they're using to
calibrate and and their own timing
mechanism and there's a they have this
other sauce which intriguingly they say
that these two sources of error one the
connection and one this other sauce
which I don't understand as they're
working in opposite directions that so
you know they could cancel each other
out if they cancel each other out then
the results still there
but at the moment they the feeling is
probably that they want and that that
result may disappear they were sitting
on this for three years they didn't know
what the you know what if there was
anything wrong you know they'd looked at
it looked at it looked at I sort of
liken it to Darwin actually when Darwin
came up with the origin of the species
his religious convictions meant that he
was very nervous about announcing it to
the scientific community and he sat on
it for years right it's a bit like that
in a way they realise the controversy of
what they were going to announce and and
so they sat on it and I wouldn't want
them to sit in it forever the right
thing to do is to open it up to the rest
of the scientific community and they can
study it and they can see if they can
find a fault I think that's the right
thing to do when we stand here and look
at those mountains it really hits home
to me how amazing it is that neutrinos
pass through mountains
what
when Fred the neutrino is passing
through that many atoms that much rock
how come nothing's hitting anything the
threat the neutrino is you I think I
think it's not a bad analogy as you
basically would replace that rock as far
as fred is concerned with nothing more
than a veil of fog or it's and you're
passing through and you just you just
bypass it right you don't you might see
it but you just would go straight
through it you're going you don't
interact with it in any real way and
it's only very occasionally will will
Fred actually feel the impact of one of
the atoms that's and in fact it better
Lee passes all the way through the rock
and the thing that they ends up
detecting it is an even more
concentrated regime of the detectors
they use a really solid detectors of
lead which has got high density of atoms
in there a better that you just got to
increase the density of atoms as much as
you can of so that the nuclei of the
atoms that you maximize the chances that
this neutrino which has got no into no
real interaction cross-section which
means they know the area that it's going
to hit with anything else that's so
small that it just passes all the way
through it's a point-like object
remember it's a fundamental object as
the neutrino it just shoots through and
you've you've got to be very lucky that
it actually hits one and and and leaves
a recoil that you can detect so you
maximize the density of material passing
through the gaps but it also is it's not
experiences it's got no charge a
neutrino has got no electric charge so
it's not feeling the effects of the
protons it's not feeling the effects of
the electrons at least in terms of the
electromagnetic interaction which is far
stronger so the protons and neutrons are
highly they're all then they're
producing electrostatic interactions but
then you Trina doesn't feel them it's
not feel that it doesn't feel the strong
interaction so this high density of
protons and neutrons which have got the
quarks in there the neutrino doesn't
feel those strong interactions the only
thing it's beginning to feel are the the
weak interactions that's the only thing
it feels and they're much
weaker than than any of the others so
basically it just goes through feels
everything is a gap personally if it
isn't proved to be a real effect I will
be gutted as a theorist are we
absolutely gutted you know this is so
exciting that you know when when it
looked like it might be a credible
result you know me is that a result you
know I'm sort of working in this field
at a time when you know as a hugely
dramatic result is occurred and you know
that really excited me and you know the
game was on to try and find ways to
explain it you know I'd already thought
of a project for one of my PhD students
potentially you know to try to explain
this result probably won't bother now so
something like a nucleus has various
weapons in its arsenal to affect other
yeah other particles and a lot of its
weapons or one of its big weapons is
neutralized in the case of a neutrino so
that's it's electric it's electrostatic
forces of neutralized and it's strong
forces are neutralized the two big
weapons it's got gone and it's just left
gravity is it irrelevant is so weak on
these scales
it's just left with the Elector with the
weak interaction with being weak means
it's very difficult to detect them yeah
I always an artist are these things I
like interesting results like this you
know you don't you don't do science for
the just to sort of do the boring old
well I don't do science to do the just
boring old stuff you know I wanted I
want to do interesting stuff I wanna do
exciting stuff you know stuff that's you
know is really sort of moving on from
what we previously thought that's what
excites me as a scientist you know maybe
you know I would like these sort of
anomalous results to come out you know
when I was doing my PhD and that's what
it was announced that the acceleration
of the universe which was last year's
Nobel Prize was was given for and you
know I remember the time people were
very skeptical about that and you know
because they are it'll just be some
systematics whatever but actually that's
turned out to sort of stood the test of
time
it seems this one might not but yeah at
the time that was a huge a zone it's
dominated my career since that
acceleration of the universe result so
you know this is what it does these
these are great things you know we
should embrace these things obviously we
need to be scientifically responsible
and you know not just jump on a band
because it's sounds good but you know
these are exciting things and as I said
I'll be gutted Thanks
in the little bit of encrypted with what
else and this is right how often do you
say that
Wow